[Música]
se cumplen 100 días desde que inició la
invasión rusa ucrania el presidente
volodymyr se le indicó que moscú
controla alrededor del 20% del
territorio ucraniano y pidió más armas a
la comunidad internacional esto mientras
continúa la ofensiva en la ciudad de
severodonezk
se mantiene el debate en eeuu por la bne
de corte de armas en declaraciones del
presidente joe bailén llamó a prohibir
la venta de armas de asalto a
particulares añadió que el congreso debe
hacer algo a raíz de los recientes
tiroteos en tulsa y hualde
se llevaron a cabo las celebraciones en
el primero de los cuatro días del
jubileo de platino de la reina isabel 2a
la monarca participó de las actividades
del jueves pero el palacio de buckingham
anunció que él no estará presente en el
servicio de acción de gracias' del
viernes tras experimentar ciertas
molestias
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas soy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en ucrania
donde el presidente volodymyr selenski
informó que aproximadamente el 20% de su
país se encuentra bajo el control ruso
el mandatario explicó que esta
superficie equivale a 125 mil kilómetros
cuadrados al tiempo que denunció que
unos 320 kilómetros cuadrados están
infectados de minas plantadas por rusia
se les que pidió más armas a la
comunidad internacional y justamente
reino unido prometió enviar misiles de
mediano alcance sumándose a eeuu y
alemania para equipar al país con
armamento capaz de derribar aviones y
destruir artillería cuando se cumplen
100 días de ofensiva rusa el presidente
ucraniano dijo que sus tropas lograron
algunos avances en el este si toda la
situación en el donbass no ha cambiado
en un día hemos tenido un éxito
particular en las batallas de
severodonezk pero es demasiado pronto
para decirlo la situación es más dura
allí como en las ciudades y
asentamientos cercanos lysychansk
y otros hay muchas ciudades de este tipo
donde continúan ataques tan poderosos
por parte de rusia si continuamos en
eeuu porque el presidente yo vaivén
pidió que se prohíban las armas de
asalto y los cargadores de alta
capacidad mientras continúa el debate
bipartidista sobre el control de armas
de fuego el mandatario aseguró que es
suficiente y solicitó que también se
refuerce la verificación de antecedentes
de los potenciales compradores
tenemos que prohibir las armas de asalto
y los cargadores de alta capacidad si no
podemos prohibir las armas de asalto
entonces debemos elevar la edad para
comprarlas de 18 a 21 años reforzar los
controles de antecedentes promulgar
leyes de almacenamiento seguro y leyes
de bandera roja derogar la inmunidad que
protege a los fabricantes de armas de la
responsabilidad abordar la crisis de
salud mental
profundizará en el trauma de la
violencia con armas de fuego y como
consecuencia de esa violencia
son medidas racionales y de sentido
común como chance myers la cámara de
representantes en estados unidos en su
mayoría demócrata a frenar la violencia
con nuevas medidas pero en el senado la
discusión es difícil para lograr que
cualquier nuevo proyecto contra el porte
de armas pase a ser ley andrás
granadillo nos cuenta más
con esta consigna niños y jóvenes de
nueva york salieron a las calles en el
mes que busca generar conciencia sobre
las armas de fuego y para pedir que se
tomen acciones ante el incremento de la
violencia en eeuu
todo el mundo aquí es una víctima todo
el mundo aquí es un testimonio de lo que
significa estar afectado por la
violencia de las armas
en chicago la ciudad vivió su fin de
semana más violento en 5 años que dejó
más de 50 personas tiroteadas en
diferentes hechos y nueve muertos
mientras tanto y con pocas expectativas
de ser aprobado por el senado en la
cámara de representantes inició el
debate de un proyecto de ley destinado a
endurecer las leyes nacionales y si
usted dice que es demasiado pronto para
tomar medidas que estamos politizando
estas tragedias para promulgar nuevas
políticas ry gears han pasado 23 años
desde columbine 15 años desde virginia
tech 10 años desde sandy hook en years
extendido demasiado pronto amigos míos
qué demonios están esperando y waiting
for y es que este miércoles en oklahoma
hubo un nuevo ataque un paciente le
disparó a su médico tras quejarse de
sentir dolor luego de una intervención
quirúrgica el atacante compró el arma de
camino al lugar de los hechos ante las
continuas noticias sobre violencia
armada la vicepresidenta kamala harris
llamó al congreso a tomar medidas
necesitamos que el congreso actúe and
share pero sé que todos pensamos lo
mismo sobre la importancia de que los
líderes líderes en temas como este
en otro caso que alertó al país el
supremacista blanco que asesinó a 10
personas en un supermercado en luz valor
nueva york se declaró no culpable de los
25 cargos de los que es acusado el
debate nacional sobre el uso de las
armas y la segunda enmienda continúa
sobre la mesa y la respuesta al problema
estaría en manos del senado
estadounidense
pasamos al salvador la ong amnistía
internacional alertó que el gobierno del
presidente en allí bukele ha cometido
graves violaciones a los derechos
humanos en medio del régimen de
excepción vigente desde finales de marzo
al tiempo que advirtió sobre la
posibilidad de una con su habilidad
penal internacional la organización
expone que al menos 23 personas
detenidas han muerto en custodia del
estado más temprano hablamos con erika
guevara rosas directora para las
américas de amnistía internacional que
nos explicó además de las denuncias por
detenciones arbitrarias porque otros
delitos se han presentado y es
importante señalar que hay un periodo de
un poco más de dos meses y desde que
inició la implementación de este régimen
de selección se han detenido a 38 mil
personas y en la mayoría de los casos se
trata de detenciones arbitrarias que no
cuentan con órdenes de aprensión o
situaciones en flagrancia pero además
amistad internacional a través de la
investigación que hemos hecho también
hemos documentado casos de violaciones
al debido proceso a la presunción de
inocencia a la defensa adecuada en
procedimientos judiciales hemos por
ejemplo verificado que las audiencias
que se dan de estas personas detenidas
que se presentan ante la autoridad
judicial son audiencias sumarias de
entre 300 y 500 personas con un par de
defensores públicos que no conocen ni
siquiera de los casos hemos recibido
informes de tortura y malos tratos sobre
todo en la detención de menores de edad
de niños niñas y adolescentes que han
sido detenidas en el contexto del
régimen de excepción y pues las 23
personas que se conocen que por lo menos
han muerto bajo custodia de las
autoridades sin que hayan dado ninguna
explicación ni siquiera que hayan
informado directamente a sus familiares
un día después de que se conociera el
veredicto en el juicio entre los actores
johnny depp y amber hertz la abogada de
heart señaló que la actriz no puede
pagar los más de 10 millones de dólares
que el jurado le impuso como
indemnización por difamar a depp en una
columna de opinión al mismo tiempo
informó que planea recurrir la sentencia
los británicos comenzaron desde el
jueves y hasta el 5 de junio las
celebraciones por los 70 años de reinado
de isabel 2a un evento único en
reinounido ya que ningún monarca
británico ha permanecido tanto tiempo en
el trono de la casa windsor
entre la larga lista de eventos el más
esperado fue el saludo de su majestad
desde el balcón en el palacio de
buckingham la reina no estará presente
en el servicio de acción de gracias'
tras experimentar ciertas molestias
veamos más
70 años de reinado de una reina tan
popular como siempre isabel segunda de
96 años apoyada en su bastón es aclamada
por la multitud frente al palacio de
buckingham la reina celebra desde este
jueves su jubileo de platino el reinado
más largo de la historia de la monarquía
británica desde la reina victoria que
estuvo 63 años al frente del imperio
británico en el famoso balcón junto a
isabel segunda su hijo el príncipe
carlos que le sucederá y su esposa
camila pero también el príncipe william
su esposa kate y sus hijos los grandes
ausentes el príncipe harry y su esposa
megan que no pudieron saludar a la
multitud desde el balcón al igual que el
príncipe andrew el hijo de la reina
acusado de agresión sexual en relación
con el caso sting a última hora de la
mañana los miembros de la monarquía
británica llegaron al palacio en
carruaje una imagen poco habitual desde
la pandemia de las tres generaciones de
la realeza juntas en un mismo vehículo
muchos fans decidieron en este centro
comercial para asegurar una buena vista
venimos de manchester y birmingham una
de mis hijas bien incluso desde parís
para que podamos estar todos juntos
llegamos a eso de las 6 de la mañana
para poder estar en primera fila y tener
la mejor vista
y estoy deseando ver a la reina en el
balcón con la familia real es la primera
vez que veo esto el heredero de la
corona el príncipe carlos reviso las
tropas en el desfile militar durante el
saludo a las banderas debido a que la
reina ya no monta a caballo aunque es a
ella a quien los británicos celebrarán
durante cuatro días más que la monarquía
lo que los británicos celebran es el
devenir de una mujer que forma parte de
su historia y de su vida cotidiana a
ustedes gracias por acompañarnos en esta
jornada informativa volvemos en breve a
quién france24
[Música]